[Music]  this holiday season witnessed the story  of the first Christmas through a whole  new set of eyes hide quickly  Deborah are you okay huh Bernie who  holds am i holding off from the studio  that brought you miracles from heaven  and laude with a Chance of Meatballs  meet the unlikely heroes behind the  greatest story ever told  carrot is up to something Mary needs  help me to save her  you're in danger you can listen to what  I'm about to say extremely carefully do  you want a belly rub you want to get to  my friends you're gonna have to get past  me first what is that what that wasn't  supposed to look  [Music]  [Music]  Debra Cyrus and Felix the new kings in  danger here's little well-placed  distraction  [Music]  wait a second are they eating chicken  ladies  [Music]